This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. On the evening of May 31st, 2009, 216 passengers, three pilots, and nine flight attendants boarded an air-france flight in Rio de Janeiro, Brazil. The flight was headed across the Atlantic Ocean to Paris. A warning. This story might not be a good one to listen to if you're sitting on a plane right now. That's producer Katie Mingle letting you know that the closest exit could be behind you. The plane that took off that evening from Rio was an Airbus 330.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。2009年5月31日晚上，216名乘客、三名飞行员和九名乘务员在巴西里约热内卢登上一架法国航空公司（Air France）的航班。这架飞机正飞往大西洋对岸的巴黎。有个警告。如果你现在正坐在飞机上，这个故事可能不太适合听。这是节目制作人凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）在提醒你，最近的安全出口可能就在你身后。那天晚上从里约起飞的飞机是一架空中客车 A330。
The takeoff was unremarkable. The plane reached a cruising altitude of 35,000 feet. The passengers read and watched movies and slept. As they flew over the Atlantic Ocean passing the equator, there was a lot of thunderstorm activity quite typical, nothing really unusual about that. That's William Longavicia. He wrote an article for Vanity Fair about this flight and has written extensively about aviation. He also used to be a pilot. So I spent many, many thousands of hours in cockpits.
起飞过程很平稳。飞机爬升到了 35,000 英尺的巡航高度。乘客们看书、看电影、睡觉。当他们飞越跨过赤道的大西洋上空时，有许多雷暴活动，这很典型，并没有什么真正不寻常的地方。这是威廉·隆加维西亚（William Longavicia）。他为《名利场》（Vanity Fair）杂志写过一篇关于这次航班的文章，并且在航空领域进行过大量写作。他以前也是一名飞行员。所以我花了好几千个小时在驾驶舱里。
Which means he's particularly well-suited to tell the story of Air France flight 447. It was a long flight. So they had two co-pilots, known as first officers and one captain. They would fly the plane in shifts. Two of them flying, well one captain. They would fly the plane in shifts, two of them flying while one slept. We know that the flight proceeded normally for several hours. And then? Then, with no communication to the ground or air traffic control, it suddenly disappeared.
这意味着他特别适合讲述法航 447 航班的故事。这是一次长途飞行。所以他们有两个副驾驶（被称为大副）和一个机长。他们将轮流驾驶飞机。其中两人飞行，嗯，还有一个机长。他们将轮流驾驶飞机，两人飞行，一人睡觉。我们知道飞行正常进行了几个小时。然后呢？然后，在与地面或空中交通管制没有任何通信的情况下，它突然消失了。
Some pieces of the plane and several bodies were found days later floating in the Atlantic, but it would be two more years before most of the wreckage was found deep in the ocean. All 228 people on board had died. When the wreckage was found, they also recovered the cockpit voice recorder and the flight data recorders. And they were in good shape. The recordings were able to tell a story about how flight 447 ended up in the bottom of the Atlantic Ocean. And the story they told was about what happened when the automated system flying the plane suddenly shut off,
几天后，人们在大西洋上漂浮着发现了飞机的一些碎片和几具尸体，但又过了两年，大部分残骸才在深海中被找到。机上 228 人全部遇难。当残骸被找到时，他们还找到了驾驶舱语音记录仪和飞行数据记录仪。它们状况良好。这些录音讲述了一个关于 447 航班最终如何坠入大西洋底的故事。而它们讲述的故事，是关于当驾驶飞机的自动化系统突然关闭时发生了什么，
and the pilots were left surprised, confused, and ultimately unable to fly their own plane. Automation in flight has been around for a long time. The first so-called autopilot was invented by the Sparry Corporation in 1912, and it allowed the plane to fly straight and level without the pilot's intervention. In the 1950s, the autopilot's got better, so that you could program an autopilot to follow a route not just to keep the wings level. This was making the pilots job a lot easier. But there was still a lot to think about in the cockpit of an airplane.
而飞行员们则感到惊讶、困惑，最终无力驾驶自己的飞机。飞行自动化已经存在很长时间了。第一个所谓的自动驾驶仪是由斯佩里公司（Sperry Corporation）于 1912 年发明的，它允许飞机在没有飞行员干预的情况下保持直线和水平飞行。在 20世纪 50 年代，自动驾驶仪变得更好了，你可以对自动驾驶仪进行编程以遵循一条航线，而不仅仅是保持机翼水平。这让飞行员的工作轻松了很多。但飞机驾驶舱里仍然有很多事情需要考虑。
Controlling the electric systems, controlling the hydraulic systems. And because of all this, most planes had three people in the cockpit, two pilots and an engineer. Flight engineers sat behind the pilots and they manipulated and managed these increasingly complex systems. But by the 1970s, all of those complex systems were also automated and flight engineers lost their necessity and their jobs.
控制电气系统，控制液压系统。正因为这一切，大多数飞机的驾驶舱里都有三个人：两名飞行员和一个机械师。飞行工程师坐在飞行员身后，他们操纵和管理这些日益复杂的系统。但到了 20世纪 70 年代，所有这些复杂的系统也都实现了自动化，飞行工程师不再必要，也失去了工作。
By this time the jet engine had replaced the piston engine, making planes much more reliable. And studies were showing that most accidents were being caused not by mechanical error, but by human error. In a French company called Airbus, thought that they could make planes safer by letting automation carry an even bigger part of the burden of flying. Airbus was a leader. Airbus has always been quite radical in its design philosophy. Led by a guy named Bernard Ziegler, Airbus set out to design what they hoped would be the safest plane yet.
此时，喷气发动机取代了活塞发动机，使飞机的可靠性大大提高。研究表明，大多数事故不是由机械故障引起的，而是由人为错误引起的。一家名为空中客车（Airbus）的法国公司认为，他们可以让自动化承担更大比例的飞行负担，从而使飞机更安全。空客是一个领导者。空客在其设计哲学上一直相当激进。在伯纳德·齐格勒（Bernard Ziegler）的领导下，空客开始设计他们希望是有史以来最安全的飞机。
A plane that even the worst pilots could fly with ease. Bernard Ziegler, he famously said that he was building an airplane that his calls Sierge could fly. Ziegler's plane not only had autopilot, it also had what's called a fly-by-wire system. So this can get a bit technical, but basically an autopilot just does what a pilot tells it to do. Fly-by-wire is a computer-based control system that can interpret what the pilot wants to do and then do it smoothly and safely. So if the pilot pulls
一架即使是最差的飞行员也能轻松驾驶的飞机。伯纳德·齐格勒，他曾有一句名言：他正在制造一架他的礼宾员（concierge）都能飞的飞机。齐格勒的飞机不仅有自动驾驶仪，还有所谓的电传操纵（fly-by-wire）系统。所以这可能会变得有点技术性，但基本上自动驾驶仪只是做飞行员告诉它要做的事。电传操纵是一个基于计算机的控制系统，可以解释飞行员想要做什么，然后平稳安全地完成它。所以如果飞行员拉动
back on his or her stick, the fly-by-wire system will say, oh, I see that you want to pitch up and here, I'll do it for you at just the right angle and rate. Importantly, the fly-by-wire system will also protect you from getting into an aerodynamic stall. So in a car, a stall happens when the engine stops turning, but in a plane, stalling is different. Basically getting so slow that the wing's no longer function correctly and the airplane loses altitude, put it that way. A stall in a plane can happen when the nose of the plane is pitched up at two steep and
他或她的操纵杆，电传操纵系统会说，哦，我看到你想抬头，来吧，我以恰好的角度和速率为你完成。重要的是，电传操纵系统还可以保护你免于进入气动失速状态。所以在汽车里，失速发生在发动机停止转动时，但在飞机上，失速是不同的。基本上就是速度变得太慢，以至于机翼不再正常工作，飞机失去高度，换句话说。当机鼻抬得太高而导致飞机失速时，
angle. A steep angle can cause the plane to lose lift and start to descend. Stalling in a plane is not good. Stoffer long enough and you will crash. But fly-by-wire automation makes it impossible to do as long as it's on. Unlike autopilot, the fly-by-wire system
一个陡峭的角度会导致飞机失去升力并开始下降。在飞机上失速可不是什么好事。持续失速足够长时间，你就会坠毁。但只要电传操纵自动化开启，它就能让这种事情不可能发生。与自动驾驶仪不同，电传操纵系统
cannot be turned on and off by the pilot. You can't turn this automation off. But here's the thing. It can turn itself off. And that's exactly what it did on May 3, 2009, as flight 447 flew through the night sky over the Atlantic Ocean. At some point, having flown normally for a few hours, the captain had gone back to sleep. This meant the two co-pilots were in control of the plane.
不能由飞行员手动开启和关闭。你无法关闭这种自动化。但问题是。它可以自行关闭。而这正是 2009 年 5 月 3 日晚，447 航班飞越夜空中大西洋上空时发生的事情。在某个时刻，在正常飞行了几个小时后，机长回去睡觉了。这意味着两个副驾驶在控制飞机。
They encountered some weather. It wasn't rough. They never hit significant turbulence. So far nothing out of the ordinary. And then suddenly, they lost airspeed indications. A pressure probe on the outside of the plane had iced over. The automation could no longer tell how fast the plane was going. At this point, autopilot disconnected.
他们遇到了一些天气。并不算恶劣。他们从未遇到过显著的湍流。到目前为止，一切都很正常。然后突然之间，他们失去了空速指示。飞机外侧的一个压力探头结冰了。自动化系统无法再判断飞机的飞行速度。此时，自动驾驶仪断开连接。
At the same time, the fly-by-wire system degraded by one step. So the autopilot turned off and the fly-by-wire system shifted into a different mode, a mode that did not protect against aerodynamic stall. None of this was ideal, but it also wasn't a reason to panic, according to William. The plane was still basically flying straight and steady. The airplane was not upset. Had they done nothing, they would have done exactly what they needed to do, nothing.
与此同时，电传操纵系统降级了一步。所以自动驾驶仪关闭了，电传操纵系统切换到了一种不同的模式，一种不防范气动失速的模式。所有这些都不是理想状态，但据威廉说，这也还不是恐慌的理由。飞机基本上仍在笔直稳定地飞行。飞机没有颠簸。如果他们什么都不做，他们就会做他们最需要做的事情：什么都不做。
But that's not what happened. The copilot in the right seat put his hand on his control stick, a little joystick-like thing to his right. And he pulled it back. Not just a little. He pulled it three-quarters of the way back. Why he did that is a major question. Perhaps he was startled or reacting to some turbulence.
但事实并非如此。坐在右侧座位的副驾驶把手放在了他的操纵杆上，那是他右边的一个类似小型操纵杆的东西。他把它拉了回来。不仅仅是一点点。他把它拉回了四分之三。他为什么这么做是个大问题。也许他吓了一跳，或者是在对某些湍流做出反应。
It's important to note that he did not tell the other pilot in the cockpit, the guy in the left seat, what he had just done. If he had, maybe his co-pilot would have known the dangerous situation they were about to be in. In an air bus, the two pilots have separate control sticks that move independently of each other. In other commercial airplanes, the two pilots have separate control sticks that move independently of each other. In other commercial airplanes, the controls would move in unison so that you would actually feel the moves your co-pilot was making on their controls.
需要指出的是，他并没有告诉驾驶舱里的另一个飞行员（左座的那个人）他刚刚做了什么。如果他说了，也许他的副驾驶就会知道他们即将陷入危险境地。在空客飞机上，两名飞行员拥有各自独立移动的操纵杆。在其他商业飞机上，两名飞行员的操纵杆会协同移动，这样你实际上能感觉到你的副驾驶在他们的操纵杆上做出的动作。
This design variation may also have contributed to what was about to become a very bad situation. In any case, as the pilot in the right seat pulled back on his stick, the airplane pulled its nose up and started to soar upward. When stall protections are in place, the plane won't just warn you not to pitch it at such an extreme angle, it physically will not let you do it. But remember, the plane had shifted into a mode in which it wasn't offering that underlying protection.
这种设计差异可能也导致了接下来这个非常糟糕的局面。无论如何，当右座飞行员拉回操纵杆时，飞机机头抬起，并开始向上飙升。当失速保护启用时，飞机不仅会警告你不要以如此极端的角度抬头，它在物理上也不允许你这样做。但请记住，飞机已经切换到了一种不再提供该底层保护的模式。
As the angle got steeper and steeper, the air couldn't flow smoothly across the wings and the plane began to stall. The plane was angled up, trying to gain altitude, but it actually began to lose altitude. A warning began to sound. The plane couldn't prevent a stall, but it could still warn that a stall was happening. It said stall, stall, stall.
随着角度越来越陡，空气无法顺畅地流过机翼，飞机开始失速。飞机机头朝上，试图获得高度，但实际上它开始失去高度。警报声开始响起。飞机无法阻止失速，但它仍然可以发出失速正在发生的警告。它喊着 stall，stall，stall。
It would have sounded like this. And you'd think that if you heard this alarm, someone would say, hey, I think we might be stalling, but this never happened. At one point, one of the copolytes did say, get your nose down. But he didn't say we've stalled, and the man in the right seat who was flying the airplane to junior copilot, he would put the nose down a couple of times and bring it right back up again. The copilot began to ring frantically for the captain to come into the cockpit, at one
听起来会是这样的。你可能会认为，如果你听到这个警报，会有人说，嘿，我想我们可能要失速了，但这并没有发生。有一点，其中一个副驾驶确实说过，压低机头。但他没有说我们失速了，而那个坐在右座、正驾驶飞机的年轻副驾驶，把机头压低了几次，然后又把它拉了回来。副驾驶开始疯狂按铃叫机长进驾驶舱，在某个
point one of them says, where is he? The airplane was shaking, all kinds of alarms were going off. One minute and 38 seconds after the episode started, the captain came into the cockpit and asked, what's going on here? The copilot did not say we're in a stall. Instead one of them said, quote, we've completely lost control of the airplane and we don't understand anything. We've tried everything. The captain had walked into a difficult scene to understand. Everyone was confused, were they descending or climbing, at times they couldn't seem to figure it out.
时刻其中一人说，他在哪儿？飞机在颤抖，各种警报器都在响。事件开始一分三十八秒后，机长走进驾驶舱，问，这里怎么了？副驾驶没有说我们在失速。相反，其中一人说，引述，“我们完全失去了对飞机的控制，我们什么都不懂。我们什么都试过了。”机长走进了一个难以理解的现场。每个人都很困惑，他们是在下降还是在爬升，有时他们似乎搞不清楚。
Finally, they seemed to realize they're in a fast descent, losing thousands of feet per minute. But why? They couldn't figure out why. The captain never assessed correctly what was going on. He was obviously trying to, he wasn't there to drink coffee or suck Islam, but he was never able to figure out what was going on, even though it should have been amply obvious what was going on.
最后，他们似乎意识到他们正在快速下降，每分钟损失数千英尺。但为什么？他们弄不清为什么。机长从来没有正确评估到底发生了什么。他显然在试图这样做，他不是来喝咖啡或偷懒的，但他始终无法弄清楚发生了什么，尽管当时到底发生了什么本该是显而易见的。
But for whatever reason, it wasn't obvious to them what was going on. They didn't know they were in a stall. If they had realized it, William says the fix would have been clear. It's basic. It's pilot school 101. The recovery would have required them to put the nose down. Power doesn't matter, just get the nose down, get it below the horizon, regain a flying speed, and then pull out of the ensuing dive. The plane continued falling down at a jaw dropping pace, losing several
但无论出于什么原因，对他们来说，发生了什么并不显眼。他们不知道自己处于失速状态。威廉说，如果他们意识到了这一点，解决办法将是明确的。这很基础。这是飞行学校 101。恢复驾驶需要他们压低机头。动力并不重要，只要把机头压下去，让它低于地平线，重新获得飞行速度，然后从随之而来的俯冲中拉起。飞机以令人咋舌的速度继续下坠，每分钟损失数千
thousands of feet per minute. But since they started at 37,000 feet, for a while there was still time for a recovery. So for quite a long time, a normal crew would have been able to recover, and at the very end at around 16,000 feet, the best crew in the world only probably would have been able to recover. And below that altitude, no crew would have been able to recover because they simply didn't have the space beneath them to execute the dive before hitting the water. But in any case, they never tried to do it.
英尺。但由于他们是从 37,000 英尺开始的，有一段时间仍然有恢复的时间。所以在相当长的一段时间里，一个正常的机组人员本能够恢复，而在最后大约 16,000 英尺时，世界上最好的机组人员可能才能够恢复。而在此高度以下，没有任何机组人员能够恢复，因为他们在撞击水面之前，根本没有下方空间来执行俯冲动作。但无论如何，他们从未尝试这样做。
And so they rode this airplane down, expressing confusion the whole time, and finally expressing certainty that they were going to die. Four minutes and twenty seconds after the incident started. They pancaked into the water at a very high descent rate, and of course it killed everyone instantly. 6 years after the crash of Flight 447, what's clear is that the pilots didn't understand what was happening to them. The big question is how. How could they have a computer yelling stall at them and not understand they were in a stall.
于是他们就这样驾驶飞机坠落，全程都在表达困惑，最后确信他们要死了。事故发生四分钟二十秒后。他们以极高的下降率拍击入水，当然这瞬间杀死了所有人。在 447 航班坠毁 6 年后，显而易见的是，飞行员并不明白自己身上发生了什么。最大的问题是如何发生的。他们怎么能听到电脑对他们大喊失速却不明白他们正在失速呢。
There were various things that contributed to the crash of 447, but automation, which has overwhelmingly made airline travel safer, also played a role in this accident. For however much automation has helped the airline passenger by increasing safety. It has had some negative consequences. In this case, it's quite clear that these pilots had had experience stripped away from them for years. William actually did the math on this. The captain of the Air France flight had logged 346 hours of flying over the past six months, but of that time, there were only about four hours in which he was actually in control of an airplane.
导致 447 航班坠毁的原因有很多，但极大地提高了航空旅行安全性的自动化，也在这次事故中起到了作用。尽管自动化通过提高安全性在很大程度上帮助了航空乘客。但也带来了一些负面影响。在这种情况下，很明显，这些飞行员多年的经验已经被剥夺了。威廉实际上对此进行了计算。法航航班的机长在过去六个月里记录了 346 小时的飞行时间，但在这些时间里，他实际控制飞机的时间只有大约四个小时。
Takeoffs and landings. The rest of the time, autopilot was flying the plane. That's four hours in six months. The co-pilot would have had even less time at the controls. This is not to say pilots do nothing when autopilot is on. They still have an important role to play. What do good pilots do in flight? They watch the systems.
起飞和降落。其余时间都是自动驾驶仪在飞。那是六个月里的四个小时。副驾驶在操纵杆上的时间会更少。这并不是说当自动驾驶仪开启时飞行员什么都不做。他们仍然扮演着重要的角色。优秀的飞行员在飞行中做什么？他们监视系统。
They handle navigation and communication. They occasionally program things in, flight path changes. They deal with anticipation of whether they think about fuel management. Increasingly, William says, pilots have become automation managers, with fewer and fewer chances to actually fly the plane. He believes this lack of experience at the controls left the pilots of 447 unprepared to take over when the automation turned off.
他们处理导航和通信。他们偶尔会输入一些东西，比如飞行路径更改。他们处理对燃油管理的预期。威廉说，飞行员越来越多地成为自动化管理者，实际驾驶飞机的机会越来越少。他认为，这种缺乏操控经验导致 447 航班的飞行员在自动化关闭时毫无准备来接管飞机。
The pilots were hideously incompetent. That's, I think, no one would disagree with that. So I have certainly heard that position from other people before. I think we all have to be very careful. None of us was there when this actually happened. That's Nadine Sardar, a systems engineer at the University of Michigan who's studied a lot of aviation accidents related to automation. My approach to things is different, I guess. These pilots were in that airplane with the passengers and I'm sure they had every motivation
飞行员非常无能。这是，我认为，没有人会不同意这一点。所以我当然以前从其他人那里听到过这种立场。我认为我们所有人都必须非常小心。当这一切发生时，我们中没有一个人在现场。这是密歇根大学的系统工程师娜丁·萨达尔（Nadine Sardar）所说的，她研究了大量与自动化相关的航空事故。我想我的方法不同。这些飞行员和乘客在那架飞机上，我确信他们有充分的动力
to keep that flight safe. And yet they didn't. So then I tried to understand, well, why did they not? Did they not have the right information? Did they not have the proper training? When one of the co-pilots hauled back on a stick, he pitched the plane into an angle that eventually caused the stall. But as possible, he didn't understand that he was now flying in a different mode, one
来保证飞行的安全。然而他们没有。所以我试图去理解，嗯，为什么他们没有？他们没有得到正确的信息吗？他们没有接受过适当的训练吗？当其中一个副驾驶猛拉操纵杆时，他把飞机拉到了最终导致失速的角度。但也有可能，他并不明白自己现在是在一种不同的模式下飞行，这种模式
that would not regulate and smooth out his movements. This confusion about how the fly-by-wire system responds in different modes is referred to, aptly, as mode confusion. And it's come up in other accidents. The plane switches into a different mode and suddenly pilots find it difficult to understand what's going on at that point. They do not exactly know whether the system is still taking care of the airplane or whether they are in charge now. They don't necessarily understand whether all of it has disconnected
不会调节和抚平他的动作。这种关于电传操纵系统在不同模式下如何反应的困惑，恰如其分地被称为模式混淆（mode confusion）。并且它在其他事故中也出现过。飞机切换到不同的模式，飞行员突然发现在那个时候很难理解发生了什么。他们不确定系统是否还在照顾飞机，或者现在是否由他们负责。他们不一定理解是否所有系统都已经断开连接
or just parts of it have disconnected. A lot of what is happening is hidden from view from the pilots. It's buried. Or the airplane starts doing something that is unexpected. And the pilot says, hey, what now what? And now what's it doing? That's a very, very standard comment in Cockpits today. What's it up to now? The pilots of Air France Flight 447 never quite say
或者只有部分断开了连接。发生的很多事情对飞行员来说是隐藏的。它是被埋藏的。或者飞机开始做一些意想不到的事情。飞行员说，嘿，现在怎么办？现在它在干什么？这在今天的驾驶舱里是一个非常非常标准的评论。它现在在干什么？法航 447 航班的飞行员从没有完全说过
what's it doing now, but they say similar things. William wasn't the only person to point out that what's it doing now is a commonly heard question in the cockpit. It seems to be almost a running joke in the industry. A joke that everyone agrees is a serious problem. What's the most often asked question in our cockpits? What's it doing now?
它现在在干什么，但他们说了类似的话。威廉并不是唯一一个指出“它现在在干什么”是驾驶舱里常见问题的人。这似乎几乎成了业内的一个常笑话。一个大家都认为是个严重问题的笑话。在我们驾驶舱里最常问的问题是什么？它现在在干什么？
That's American Airlines Captain Warren Vanderberg addressing a group of pilots in 1997. People have been talking about this issue way before the crash of Flight 447. It's just that no one's really figured out how to solve it yet. But you see, we have become what I call children of the magenta. The children of the magenta are too dependent on the guiding magenta colored lines on their screens. You know, we think we have to have those magenta lines
这是美国航空公司（American Airlines）机长沃伦·范德伯格（Warren Vanderberg）于 1997 年向一群飞行员发表的讲话。早在 447 航班坠毁之前，人们就已经在讨论这个问题了。只是还没有人真正弄清楚如何解决它。但你看，我们已经变成了我所说的“洋红色之子”（children of the magenta）。洋红色之子过于依赖他们屏幕上引导性的洋红色线条。你知道，我们认为我们必须在地图上拥有那些洋红色线条
on the map and that magenta V bar that's steering us toward that line. The children of the magenta are too dependent on automation in general. And if this is you I'm talking about, do not be defensive. In the industry we created you like this. Vanderberg recommends in certain situations to turn off the autopilot and fly the plane yourself. When you deem the situation is right, to practice your skills, turn off your autopilot and your auto throttles, fly your planes,
以及将我们引向那条线的洋红色 V 形条。洋红色之子总体上过于依赖自动化。如果我说的就是你，请不要防备。在这个行业中，是我们把你造就成这样的。范德伯格建议在某些情况下关闭自动驾驶仪，自己驾驶飞机。当你认为情况合适时，为了练习你的技能，关闭自动驾驶仪和自动油门，驾驶你的飞机，
maintain your skills. Nadine Sardar agrees that this could help. She also recommends more and better training, using simulators to let pilots explore different kinds of emergency scenarios. And then of course, there are people who think the problem can be solved with more and better automation, but this is a paradox of automation. Automation accommodates incompetence, in fact it's designed to do that. The Airbus was designed after all, for Bernard Ziegler's concierge to be able to fly.
保持你的技能。娜丁·萨达尔同意这会有所帮助。她还建议进行更多更好的培训，使用模拟器让飞行员探索各种不同的应急场景。当然，也有人认为可以通过更多更好的自动化来解决这个问题，但这正是自动化的悖论。自动化顺应了无能，事实上它的设计就是为了做到这一点。毕竟，空客就是为了伯纳德·齐格勒的礼宾员能够飞行而设计的。
We appear to be locked into a cycle in which automation begets the erosion of skills or the lack of skills in the first place. And this then begets more automation. Nadine Sardar thinks it's a mistake to throw more automation at the problem. The position I would adopt is one that has been termed a human-centered automation, where we see what you need to do instead is make the automation that you have, make it A, maybe smarter, but importantly make it what we call a team player. And part of that is to provide better feedback. Part of it is have the automation communicate more effectively with the pilot.
我们似乎被锁在一个循环中，在这个循环中，自动化导致了技能的侵蚀或一开始就缺乏技能。而这反过来又带来了更多的自动化。娜丁·萨达尔认为，向问题投入更多自动化是一个错误。我将采取的立场被称为“以人为中心的自动化”（human-centered automation），在这里我们看到你需要做的是让现有的自动化，让它 A，也许更聪明，但重要的是让它成为我们所说的一个“团队成员”。其中一部分是提供更好的反馈。一部分是让自动化与飞行员进行更有效的沟通。
No one I talk to is advocating going back to the battle days before automation. So automation in general, the fly by wire systems, all of those certainly do increase safety I would argue. And even though a lot of the accidents we see these days have to do with the interaction between pilots and automation, William says you have to remember. One of the reasons for that is that because of automation, there are hardly any other accidents. And as far as how we should feel about air France flight 447 and other accidents involving automation, should they be seen as an acceptable loss in an industry that's become mostly safer through automation?
我交谈过的没有人主张回到自动化之前的糟糕日子。所以总的来说，自动化、电传操纵系统，所有这些绝对都提高了安全性，我认为。尽管我们今天看到的很多事故都与飞行员和自动化之间的互动有关，但威廉说你必须记住。其中的一个原因是，由于自动化，几乎没有任何其他事故了。至于我们应该如何看待法航 447 航班和其他涉及自动化的事故，它们是否应该被视为一个主要通过自动化变得更安全的行业中可以接受的损失？
I think as a society, the answer to that is yes. For the individuals, there's no such thing as an acceptable loss. These are terrible trash. Terrible. And for the pilots who died as well. Airbus planes are not any less safe or any more safe than any other plane on the market. Plains have accidents. But it should be said that they're pretty safe too. The accident rate for air travel is very low.
我认为作为一个社会，这个问题的答案是肯定的。对于个人来说，没有“可以接受的损失”这种东西。这些都是可怕的坠毁。太可怕了。对于死去的飞行员来说也是如此。空客飞机并不比市面上的任何其他飞机更不安全，也没有更安全。飞机确实会发生事故。但必须说明的是，它们也相当安全。航空旅行的事故率非常低。
About 2.8 accidents for every 1 million departures. And there are plenty of pilots out there that know how to take control in an emergency. So breathe deep everyone, just relax. It's going to be okay. It's true, there are lots of good pilots out there. But in a far off future, we might be flying in pilotless planes. We're a long way from that, but the technology is definitely coming and we will, I mean, this will happen and it just makes a lot of sense. I don't think anyone is sort of loudly saying great, that's just going to be a wonderful thing. But I think reasonable people are also not
大约每 100 万次起飞有 2.8 起事故。外面有大量的飞行员知道如何在紧急情况下接管飞机。所以大家深呼吸，放松点。一切都会好的。确实，外面有很多优秀的飞行员。但在遥远的未来，我们可能会乘坐无飞行员的飞机飞行。我们离那还很远，但这项技术绝对会到来，我们将会——我的意思是，这将会发生，这非常有意义。我不认为有人会大声说太棒了，这将会是一件美妙的事情。但我认为理性的人也不会
tearing their hair out about it. Because by the time it happens, the automation will be so good and so reliable that humans, with all of our human emotions and human fallibility, the children of the magenta, will really just be in the way. 99% invisible was produced this week by Katie Mingle with Sam Green span Avery Truffleman and me Roman Mars. We relied heavily on the reporting and expertise of William Lungavisha for this piece, so special thanks to him, he went above and beyond for us, and if you want an even more in-depth minute by minute analysis of the crash of Flight 4447, check out his piece in Vanity Fair. It's called the Human Factor.
为此抓狂。因为当它发生时，自动化将是如此之好、如此可靠，以至于人类带着我们所有的脆弱情感和人类易错性——洋红色之子——真的只会碍手碍脚。99% invisible 本周由凯蒂·明格尔与萨姆·格林斯潘（Sam Green span）、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼（Avery Truffleman）以及我罗曼·马尔斯共同制作。我们在很大程度上依赖了威廉·隆加维西亚的报道和专业知识来完成这篇作品，所以特别感谢他，他为我们付出了超越常规的努力，如果你想对 4447 航班的坠毁进行更深入的每分钟分析，请查看他在《名利场》上的作品。它被称为《人为因素》（The Human Factor）。
And on the next episode of 99% of Asphalt, we're going to take this idea of the Automation Paradox and use it as a lens to view the next great design challenge in automation. When we all potentially become the children of the magenta in our self-driving cars, it's our first two-part series, so stay tuned. Now, last week I mentioned that we have a new addition to the radiotopia collective, and I'm pleased to announce that Nate Dimaio's The Memory Palace is joining the gang. When I was first thinking about starting 99% of his role, Nate was one of the first people I called because I really love what he was doing with his show featuring these poignant historical
在下一集的 99% of Asphalt 中，我们将把这个“自动化悖论”的概念作为一个镜头，来观察自动化领域中下一个伟大的设计挑战。当我们所有人都可能成为自驾车里的洋红色之子时，这是我们的前两个系列节目，所以请继续关注。现在，上周我提到我们的 radiotopia 集体有了一个新成员，我很高兴地宣布内特·迪梅奥（Nate Dimaio）的《记忆宫殿》（The Memory Palace）加入了这个大家庭。当我最初考虑开始制作 99% 的广播时，内特是我第一个打电话的人之一，因为我真的很喜欢他用他的节目所做的事情，这些节目以这些凄美的历史
moments and I wanted to do something in the same spirit with stories about design. And so more than any other program I can say, if you love 99% of visible, you will love love the memory balance. Nate and I are friends and he once recommended a history book to me, and on page 325 I noticed a couple of sentences, just a couple of sentences, that were a tiny but really striking digression from the main narrative, and I'd like to think that I would have noticed the charm of this historical footnote on my own, but the real reason it stood out to me was because I knew it sparked an episode of the memory palace. Most memory palace pieces start on page 325 of a simbook.
时刻为特色，我想以同样的精神做一些关于设计的故事。因此，我可以比任何其他节目都更自信地说，如果你喜欢 99% Invisible，你会喜欢《记忆宫殿》。我和内特是朋友，他曾经向我推荐过一本历史书，在第 325 页我注意到几句话，仅仅几句话，它们是对主叙事的一个微小但非常引人注目的题外话，我想认为我会自己注意到这个历史脚注的魅力，但它对我有吸引力的真正原因是我知道它引发了《记忆宫殿》的一集。大多数《记忆宫殿》的作品都从一本厚书的第 325 页开始。
That voice you just heard is Nate D'Ameo. The Memory Palace has a special way of zeroing in on these moments in history that light up your imagination and hit you in the gut or make you smile. I had noticed that there were these historical things that would jump out from long Ken Burns documentaries or the one moment in some historic home tour
你刚才听到的声音是内特·迪梅奥。《记忆宫殿》有一种特殊的方法，可以锁定历史中那些点燃你的想象力、击中你的内心或让你微笑的时刻。我注意到有一些历史事件会从长篇肯·伯恩斯（Ken Burns）纪录片中跳出来，或者在某个历史故居参观时出现那一刻，
when that object on the mantel piece actually jumps out and says, wow, that's amazing. Look at that beautiful thing. And so often, I noticed that the things that moved me were these focused things. They were recognizing the single object. They were the incredible twist in someone's story. And I wanted to find out on some level if there was a way to cut to the chase.
当壁炉台上的那个物件突然跳出来说，哇，太神奇了。看那个美丽的东西。很多时候，我注意到打动我的东西都是这些专注的事情。它们是对单一物体的认可。它们是某人故事中的不可思议的转折。我想在某种程度上找出是否有办法直奔主题。
If there was a way to focus so tightly, it was almost just an aesthetic artistic challenge. Like, is there a way that I can replicate this feeling of being moved or having my head blown off or having my heart broken? This thing that I have once felt is there a way that I can get people to feel that same thing. Like, can I retell the story in such a way that they don't have to take the whole historical home tour, or they don't have to sit through all nine and a half hours of this documentary series? Is there a way to kind of crystallize it and turn this sweeping historical story into a pop song. But the memory palace is never just a simple historical anecdote.
是否有办法如此专注，以至于它几乎只是一种审美的艺术挑战。就像，有没有一种方法可以复制这种被打动、脑洞大开或心碎的感觉？我曾经感受过的这种东西，有没有办法让人们感受到同样的东西？就像，我能否以这样一种方式重新讲述这个故事，让他们不必进行整个历史故居的参观，或者他们不必坐下来看完这整个九个半小时的纪录片系列？有没有一种方法可以将其结晶，把这个宏大的历史故事变成流行歌曲？但《记忆宫殿》绝不仅仅是一个简单的历史轶事。
There's always something more going on. Like there is a subject and then there is meaning. Like there are themes which is different than plot. At some level I'm not merely trying to tell a historical story, I'm trying to conjure it, trying to have it sort of like live in the listener's mind for a bit, and then melt away. I really like his show so much that at a hard time, selecting which episode to present.
总有更多的事情在发生。就像有一个主题，然后有意义。就像有主题（themes）这与情节（plot）不同。在某种程度上，我不仅仅是在试图讲述一个历史故事，我是在试图召唤它，试图让它在听众的脑海中生活一会儿，然后消逝。我真的很喜欢他的节目，以至于在很难抉择时，不知道该展示哪一集。
So I asked Nate which episode really stood out to him as the one that did all the things he was hoping to achieve in the memory palace, and he picked this episode. Enjoy. This is the memory palace. I'm Nate Demetre. The world loved a world's fair.
所以我问内特，哪一集最让他脱颖而出，认为那是实现了他在《记忆宫殿》中所有希望实现的集数，他选了这一集。请欣赏。这里是《记忆宫殿》。我是内特·迪梅奥。全世界都热爱世博会。
And the exposition universel in Paris in 1889, just killed. The exhibits in the grounds were unparalleled and impeccable. And at the center of it all was this audacious steel structure that managed to be imposing and elegant and the tallest thing on earth and unmistakably French all at once. Paris had the Eiffel Tower and the men planning the next fair, the Colombian exposition in Chicago, just a couple of years away, needed something that good, something Eiffel Tower good. And that wasn't easy to find.
1889 年在巴黎举办的“世界博览会”（exposition universel）简直大获成功。展地中的展品无与伦比、无可挑剔。这一切的中心是这个大胆的钢结构，它既威严又优雅，是地球上最高的建筑物，同时又带有无可误认的法兰西风格。巴黎拥有埃菲尔铁塔，而计划在几年后举办下一届世博会（芝加哥哥伦布纪念博览会）的人们，需要一些同样优秀的东西，一些像埃菲尔铁塔一样优秀的东西。这并不容易找到。
The proposals ran from the ridiculous, like a structure that would soar more than a thousand feet above the land of Lincoln made entirely out of stack logs, in top with a replica of Abe's boyhood at home, to the extra ridiculous. Something so tall that visitors would take an elevator to the top of a slot, that they'd ride down until it dropped them off in New York or San Francisco. The Ferris organizers were panicking. They demanded that America's designers and engineers step up. In a man named George Ferris, step forward.
提案五花八门，从荒谬的开始，比如一个完全由堆叠的原木制成、高耸于林肯土地上一千多英尺以上的建筑，顶部带有亚伯童年故居的复制品，一直到超级荒谬的。高到让游客坐电梯到狭缝顶部，然后一路乘电梯下降，直到把他们送到纽约或旧金山。费尔斯（Ferris）的组织者们惊慌失措。他们要求美国的 designers 和工程师们挺身而出。一个名叫乔治·费尔斯（George Ferris）的人站了出来。
When his Ferris wheel was completed that summer. It rose 264 feet above the ground, which was a lot shorter than the Eiffel Tower. But whatever, that thing didn't even move. The idea that something's so massive, but that looks so fragile, like a bicycle wheel whose spokes look too thin to keep a bike up, was thrilling and pretty terrifying. Despite what the engineer said,
当他的摩天轮在那年夏天完工时。它高出地面 264 英尺，比埃菲尔铁塔矮得多。但管他呢，那东西甚至还会动。这样一个庞大但看起来如此脆弱的概念——就像一个自行车轮，其辐条看起来太细而无法支撑一辆自行车——既惊心动魄又相当可怕。尽管工程师们这么说，
despite the math and laws of physics, despite the many assurances of the fairs organizers, there were people who were sure that this ludicrous machine was going to be a disaster. The people were going to die. Not only was there no way that that flimsy thing could stand up to a prairie wind or a gale off the lake. Even if it did, the prospect of tumbling through the air in a cage 20 stories above Chicago was full on craziness. Who in their right mind was going to want to ride that thing? Hundreds of thousands of people did. Despite the fact that during its first test run, hundreds of bolts in loose parts rained
尽管有数学和物理定律，尽管世博会组织者一再保证，但仍然有人确信这个荒谬的机器将是一场灾难。人们会死的。不仅这个薄弱的东西绝对经不起草原风或湖面大风的吹袭。即使它经受住了，在芝加哥上空 20 层楼高的笼子里在空中翻滚的前景也完全是疯狂的。谁会脑子正常地想去坐那个东西呢？成千上万的人去了。尽管事实上在它的第一次试运行期间，数百个螺栓和松动的零件像雨点般
down on spectators below. Despite real stories of panic riders trying to escape through the windows when they realized exactly how high 200 feet was. Despite apocryphal stories of suicides and severed limbs, this ferris wheel, this thing that is basically a kitty ride today, was a bigger thrill ride than any quintuple loop open car reverse twist rocket coaster they might have at six flags. The papers, even some in France, said it was the marvel of the age, better than the Eiffel Tower.
砸向下面的观众。尽管有真实的恐慌乘客在意识到 200 英尺究竟有多高时试图通过窗户逃生的故事。尽管有关于自杀和肢体断裂的戏说传闻，但这个摩天轮，这个在今天基本上只是儿童游乐设施的东西，比他们在六旗乐园（Six Flags）可能拥有的任何五重循环开放式汽车反向扭转火箭过山车都更令人兴奋。报纸，甚至法国的一些报纸，都说它是时代的奇迹，比埃菲尔铁塔还要好。
That almost mundane sensation we have now of looking down from above, of moving through space, up and out, and down and back around. No one had ever felt those things before, and of course now we can't really feel them again. We've gone around too many times, and we've looped too many loops. But back in 1893, you could pay your 50 cents and climb into a car right after sunset during the golden hour. And experience something entirely new. You could rise up above the world's fair, where down below Americans were eating hamburgers for the first time.
我们现在从高处俯视、在太空中移动、向上向外、向下向后环绕的那种几乎平淡无奇的感觉。以前从来没有人感受过这些东西，当然现在我们真的无法再次感受到它们了。我们已经转了太多圈，也兜了太多圈子。但在 1893 年，你可以在日落后的黄金时段支付 50 美分，爬上一辆车。并体验完全崭新的事物。你可以升到世博会上方，在下方，美国人正在历史上第一次吃汉堡，
We're Buffalo Bill and Frederick Douglass and Mark Twain were sightseeing. We're entire villages from Egypt and Algeria had been brought and reconstructed. We're people who had ragged time for the first time. Sohuli dancers and belly dancers. And you could come back to Earth and walk out and be among the first people in human history to walk
水牛比尔（Buffalo Bill）、弗雷德里克·道格拉斯（Frederick Douglass）和马克·吐温（Mark Twain）正在观光。来自埃及和阿尔及利亚的整个村庄被搬来并重建。人们第一次品尝到玉米饼。还有呼啦舞者和肚皮舞者。然后你可以回到地面上走出来，成为人类历史上第一批在夜间
around at night. We light on. But fairs end, they shut down, they pack up and leave, and the Ferris wheel did too. They moved it up to a different park in the north side of the city, and after a while the novelty was gone. And the Ferris wheel became just a Ferris wheel and they tore it down. A salvage company bought it for 8 grand and blew it up with dynamite and sold the pieces for scrap. That's the memory palace from Nate to Mayo, now from radio toopia. After a couple years of not putting the show out very regularly, TV shows, books, and
亮着灯散步的人。但世博会结束了，它们关闭了，打包离开了，摩天轮也是如此。他们把它搬到了城市北部的另一个公园，过了一会儿，新鲜感就消失了。摩天轮变成了普通的摩天轮，他们把它拆毁了。一家回收公司以 8000 美元的价格买下了它，用炸启动将其炸毁，并将碎片作为废品出售。这是内特·迪梅奥的《记忆宫殿》，现在来自 radiotopia。在断断续续停止定期发布节目几年后，做电视节目、书籍和
stuff, I'm pleased to say he's releasing weekly episodes through the summer, so get on board. You're going to want to set aside five minutes or so to listen to it. The moment each new episode comes out, that's what I'm going to be doing. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook. You get little hints of what's coming up on the show if you pay attention to Facebook. We're also on Twitter, Instagram, Tumblr, and Spotify too. But if you want to learn all the things there is to know about 99% of visible, the best
其他事情，我很高兴地说他将在整个夏天每周发布新剧集，所以快来收听吧。你会想要留出五分钟左右的时间来听它。每当新的一集出来时，这就是我要做的事情。你可以在 Facebook 上找到这个节目并给它点赞。如果你关注 Facebook，你会得到关于节目即将内容的少量提示。我们也在 Twitter、Instagram、Tumblr 和 Spotify 上。但如果你想了解关于 99% Invisible 的一切，最好的
place to do that is at 99pi.org Radio Tapio From PRX There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
地方就是 99pi.org。来自 PRX 的 Radio Tapio。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。